new amsterdam season three episode one
let's go
shout out to everyone who's gotten their
vaccine this is our shot
is an amazing campaign of our healthcare
workers showing themselves getting their
shots talk about leading by example and
i hope that everyone talks to their
primary care doctors or other health
professionals about getting their
vaccines linking my videos on vaccines
down below
i did one with mama dr jones in case you
are pregnant or thinking about getting
pregnant as well
i just wanted to tell everyone how proud
i am of
this whole hospital i don't know how i
feel about this beard on him
i i think i liked him without the beard
you know actually him and i
before the pandemic walked in a blue
jacket fashion show to raise money for
prostate cancer he's quite the model
i am committed to fixing the cracks
around here okay the system
abandoned us when we needed it most
and i i vow uh
i vow to fix the system that left us
overburdened since when do hospitalists
have a conversation about something very
important like hospital funding in
hallways around patients there's
conference rooms for a reason
okay is this a sully moment u.s airways
flight 1549
landing on the freezing cold hudson
river all because of heroic captain
sully and his fabulous crew whoa
this is a sully moment
that looked like a fairly smooth landing
i mean outside of some bumps and bruises
and depending on how cold it is some
hypothermia i think everyone should be
pretty safe on board
but obviously because it's a medical
drama that's not going to be the case
ma'am we're going to take good care of
you okay let's get a trauma one day i
need an ekg of portable chest and full
blow panel including coax
ordering blood tests in a situation like
this is important but the first thing
you want to do is get big
large bore ivs into both arms to give
fluids
and blood in case the person's bleeding
out that kind of access is the most
important thing to someone's survival
obviously airway and breathing as well
but
i already saw that she is in fact airway
clear and breathing
neck veins descended with muffled hearts
tamponade from blunt force trauma
that means she's actually bleeding in an
enclosed space into the lung cavity into
the cardiac cavity and as a result
if you have so much fluid around the
heart it can't expand fully because when
a heart beats it doesn't just contract
it actually has to relax and if it
doesn't have room to relax and expand it
actually doesn't get enough blood flow
to itself
because it's a muscle it needs its own
level of circulation co-pilot with deep
abdominal blood lack and blood loss
heart rate up to 118 bp down to 108 so
with a patient who's bleeding from the
abdomen has a laceration to the abdomen
a low blood pressure with a high pulse
could mean that that person's bleeding
out losing blood because what's
essentially happening is you're losing
pressure in this closed arterial and
venous system in the circulatory system
and your heart is trying to compensate
by increasing the heart rate to try and
get more blood flow to the areas that
aren't getting enough oxygenation it's a
com
compensatory mechanism there we'll do
our best to stay out of your way we just
need to interview every crew member and
passenger who may have pertinent
information well roger that
uh sorry uh as long as it doesn't
interfere with patient care i will help
in any way i can
understood we want to start with the
pilots captain starks
they'll find them for you why are they
going to the director of the hospital
for this like
if they just walked in went to the head
triage person
in the emergency room they can get all
this information they are law
enforcement technically
they don't need to go to the chairperson
of the hospital it's your job to
investigate and it's our job
to heal so once we're done dr goodwin
to clarify you're blocking access to a
key witness
i'm pretty sure if you come with a
federal subpoena or like a judge's order
you can get the hospital to order some
blood tests but i think a patient has
the right to refuse
unless it's like one of these like very
specific orders by the court and i think
as a pilot you sort of give up that
right
and allow them to test your blood i
could be wrong here though pilots weigh
in
you smell that someone chewing gum
mince candy anything down it's the
co-pilot
it smells like ethylene glycol
antifreeze
when the plane crashed maybe a hose
snapped our open abdominal wound
absorbed it which is why we can't get
the blood
out to push from it should act as an
antidote that's a very
advanced situation that a part of the
antifreeze of the plane stabbed them in
the stomach and is now
pouring that poison into his stomach
jesus what a story
oh well he must have been stabbed with
tubing that had ethanol
ethylene glycol from the airplane and
then it pumped into his stomach and then
hurt his bile duct because the liver
enzymes were slightly inflamed like
oh never happening in reality liver
enzymes are elevated
how high three and a half times normal
that's so mild
liver enzymes being elevated three half
times normal is not great but it could
be just shock because it's not getting
enough circulation
that's a good time to mention some stuff
about liver enzymes they're called
oftentimes lfts which is liver function
tests
but the reality is they do not represent
whether or not your liver is functioning
well they're actually
signs of liver inflammation that if you
have damage to the liver you actually
leak these enzymes and as a result if
they're elevated
your liver function tests are saying
that there's damage to your liver
now what bp falling temps dropping she's
septic
starter on amp jet and flagella hang a
bag of dopamine at two mics a minute how
do they not start that already the
patient is
open wound from a trauma like you should
have started them on antibiotics broad
spectrum
enzymes are six times normal liver is
not going to last much longer
i need to expose the entire organ you'd
need to extend the surgical field across
the whole abdomen
laparotomy scalpel do you want to call
in gastro no there's no time
you mind getting your hands dirty of
course not but
it's been a few years you have a steady
hand well yes clear field division
yes still like that thai food place on
17th
yes then what are you waiting for last i
remember she was an oncologist
am i wrong she yeah she is why is she
operating
why is the oncologist operating we've
got a problem with shanez
dissecting aortic aneurysm couldn't see
it till i drained out the fluid
that's a problem so basically an
aneurysm is a ballooning of the main
artery uh that's
usually coming off of the aorta which is
the main artery that comes off of the
heart
if you have this ballooning meaning
there's a weakness in the wall and a
dissecting aortic aneurysm means that
there's a tear
inside this wall these ballooning
sections of the arteries these aneurysms
are more likely to tear because there's
less tissue there it's thinner
what does that mean dr walsh the aorta
could rupture well if it tears it's
basically rupturing
a lot of times the classic sign is a
patient comes in either with
very bad chest pain or very bad back
pain and sometimes
these uh dissecting aortic aneurysms are
missed because sometimes doctors
unfortunately misdiagnose it as like
back pain or some kind of sciatic type
pain when the reality is they need to
rule out this dissecting uric aneurysm
which can be done with an x-ray an ekg
or a cheetah scan
an ultrasound what are you doing we're
not sending another patient off into the
great unknown when i can help them right
here
right now we just paid cardio she's not
your patient they're all my patients
how is she gonna perform a repair an
aortic aneurysm repair
in the i don't understand
advancing catheter okay i'm at the aorta
is she really performing some kind of
aortic repair as an er physician i don't
know like i've never heard of this or
seen this
someone please tell me if this is i'm
wrong here i i don't think this is
appropriate bp
is dropping dissections extending
drainage greater than 200. the hell are
you doing
trying to stop the dissection no you
didn't you made it worse i'm trying to
fix it
not fast enough thanks to you going
rogue i got to crack her chest here
the way that they were trying to repair
it was putting in a catheter going
through
the blood vessel to go from the interior
portion and attack that problem the tear
from the inside of the artery with that
failing now they have to go out from the
outside and open the chest which means a
longer recovery time higher risk
et cetera et cetera ma'am we are
authorized to speak to any individual
who may have information hey
whoa whoa whoa enough you don't have the
right to come into this hospital and rip
a patient
away from their doctor violating hipaa
rules as a matter of fact we do
yeah that's what i was looking for what
is this a federal order i'm kind of
proud of myself and i think legal eagle
will be proud too that i said a federal
judge has to order this
and he said it's a federal lawyer smart
smart so i'll ask one more time
where's the pilot now you could be in
trouble for obstructing justice
all right so on takeoff if a pilot
discovers that his airspeed indicator is
giving him an inaccurate reading
and he is flying too slow what would
that pilot do why is the hospital staff
doing this investigation
get the nose down you you'd go into the
dive in order to gain speed and then you
you you'd lift up at the very end
which is exactly what you did right
you think that captain starks
jeopardized the lives of 150 people we
think he saved the lives of 150 people
oh yeah with this information that you
just got five seconds ago
i've ranked all the medical dramas that
i've watched including new amsterdam see
where it falls on my list by clicking
here and as always stay happy healthy